tim ryan was the recruiting director for
a chicago consulting company and he
founded a multi-million dollar executive
search firm
he was also a drug addict people have
this misconception that
an opiate addict is the homeless person
on the corner with the brown paper back
that's five percent uh you know the
average opiate addict is a 22 year old
white middle class male and a 23 year
old white middle class female
the disease of addiction does not
discriminate after using for years
he caught his son using heroin and
opiates
and joined him my son and i that's how
we bonded nick and i
bonded by doing drugs every day
then for tim came addiction prison and
sobriety
for his son nick a cycle of addiction
jail rehab and relapse
on the day tim recorded his 21st month
of sobriety
nick suffered a fatal overdose the
doctor took me to the room right next to
where we were
and i walked in there
and to see my 20 year old son's
cold blue lifeless body just laying
there with a sheet up to his chest and
he still had the device in his mouth
where they were
trying to aspirate him i mean
tears just started flowing down now with
his wife
former supermodel jennifer jimenez he
helps former addicts through their
substance abuse program
dope to hope often users begin with
legally prescribed painkillers after an
injury then when those run out they move
on to heroin
or fentanyl a powerful and dangerous
synthetic opioid bought from street
corner drug dealers
for too many opioid users the journey
through addiction
ends like this john can you hear me
in overdose on a street corner the lucky
ones survive to end up
here in the emergency room now seeing
more opioid overdoses than ever
overdoses are up 55 percent in 2020
compared to 2019
black people and inner city people have
a more
challenging time recovering
because the drug is so available in
their communities
one opioid manufacturer oxycontin maker
perdue pharma has acknowledged its role
in the opioid epidemic
the company has paid 634 million dollars
in fines and pleaded guilty to
contributing to
thousands of opioid deaths now surging
as the pandemic drives many
back to drugs they need purpose and
connection they need that human
interaction
and unfortunately a lot of people are
going back to uh
abusing and using opiates and when
you're messing with opiates uh
you know you're gonna die it is an
epidemic growing within a pandemic
as the number of fatal opioid overdoses
continues
to rise john hendren al jazeera chicago
let's take a closer look at the sacklers
forbes magazine estimates the family
fortune to be worth
more than 10 billion dollars it dates
back to 1952 when three brothers bought
the company that would become purdue
pharma
it went on to produce the prescription
painkiller oxycontin in the 1990s
earning the sackler's billions of
dollars
over the years the family became known
as philanthropists giving millions of
dollars to the arts
many of those cultural institutions have
since distanced themselves from the
family but they've continued to argue
that they
served as only passive board members
heidi joe castro joins me now live from
capitol hill
heidi why after purdue farmer settled
out of court and accepted its role
in the opioid crisis other sacklers
being questioned by a congressional
committee
now
well kim many are saying that although
the settlement we saw in november
was pretty big by normal people's
standards 225 million dollars paid out
by uh the sackler family that in fact
that's only a drop in the bucket
uh in this family's vast wealth that
accumulated
at the cost of more than 400 000
lives the people who have died as a
result of the opioid crisis
in fact 225 million is just two percent
of this family's net net worth
and another criticism that the
settlement received is that it
essentially allows the sale of oxycontin
to continue
even today purdue pharma agreed to go on
a bankruptcy
and that also was to forego what
potentially could have been
two billion dollars worth of penalties
that the company did not have to pay and
so democrats in congress
as well as many states that are suing
the company
said that this was not a fair deal at
all
and in fact the family has to this day
not acknowledged any wrongdoing or
liability
that was a protection that they earned
as part of the settlement with the
department of justice
and democrats are saying that simply was
unfair and today we are expecting for
the first time to see
two members of the family appear be
remotely before this congressional
hearing
expect their feet to be held to the fire
they are appearing begrudgingly under
threat of subpoena
and the ceo of pardue firm pharma will
be testifying as well
and his testimony expected to address
some of these
ongoing uh lawsuits that the company
continues to face
at a cost of some 10 billion dollars
that states and local communities have
suffered
as a result of this opioid crisis kim
we will be staying across that hearing
of course for now heidi joe castro thank
you